[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT chapter 24
hello hello we are back in fallout 3
dirty RT is wearing his beautiful Sunday
hat yeah and we are going to see if we
can find our dad I guess cuz that's
that's what you do in Fallout like we
just passed by a dead person on the
ground lots of dead people I was just in
here we murdered lots of people but they
don't seem to care
nope so that's fine so we're gonna find
our dad yes eat some spinach get big
switch to my sniper while I'm up here
good idea the maps not loading yeah hit
a little jump it's gonna kill you it'll
probably kill me nice dude now I landed
it
did I pass it oh boy pass Oh or it's
somewhere around town oh look for a
garage well it's got to be this right
here ah looks like it's it oh this is it
all right time to hop off thanks for the
lift
thanks for the lift big Rd oh I need to
find my dad I heard he's in you
somewhere got here nothing oh my god
whose dog dead dog dead dog damn my head
I never did that I don't know if I ever
did this do you have to do it yeah this
part of the main quest alright remember
it being in a vault here's the mixing in
this game not great by today's standards
knock knock hello anyone home
hello you see my dad loved one please
redress in your vote oh the brain
what's that a lot yeah I remember this
oh oh that was freaky now that's a
that's a good-looking dog right here oh
the dogs names doc come here doc now my
boy again I look for my dad you see my
dad where's my dad
fine I know I'm trying to find dad get
out my face
I don't like being small yeah dad we're
all yeah yeah yeah you will break oh my
god going to a house Oh who's that oh
all right well I can't go in any houses
so let's do dad where yeah nice the flip
wow you are small you're like a
cockroach oh whoa you climb that I'm
coming dad all right maybe we uh maybe
we'd be a little bit bigger is that
right you look a little tiny still that
toy looks awfully big yeah that's
awesome just where I belong dad I'm
stuck get me out of here dad I'm hungry
give me food
hey there's sport beautiful day isn't it
no say you should go talk to Betty she's
waiting for you over on the playground
yeah let's do me to do get back here
kick his ass
get back here get back here this is
hopeless
listen at least a little sister it's
okay it's against the rules I can fix it
but you better not do it again can we
play now I've been ever so patient
oh don't be mean that's not a good way
to start you can't do that here and now
what what
[Music]
you can't do that here and now you have
to pick
you know weird how it why does it get
all along Nate or ever I don't know so I
figured it did it before cuz I shrunk
myself but now I'm normal size I want to
try it one more time with God know you
can see if she can kill me I like this
idea alright I'm back
Oh Betty you think you can kill me you
can't do that here you wanna bet
can't move Betty
alright this is the house oh here he is
yeah you like that Thank You Jimmy yeah
I'm positive as you cry didn't uh where
is he going
[Music]
twilight zone [ __ ] who's you mean Mike
crap and you said you didn't what I was
hoping for more than for what but
entertainment has been difficult to come
and was that you've been apprised yeah
oh my god
there you are got her
Oh Rock well I Got News for you Oh get
up it's just a simulation she's fine
yeah let me just go like okay just
heating it out
it's on sick where are you going
have you seen my dad anyone home
yep it's gone yes
oh wow
[Music]
run hello
that's right
hello
sure yeah anyone else here no okay I'm
leaving no please my cart little brat
huh oh hell yes got it taken care of
Oh
dad come on
oh whoa what Jake work we're back oh my
god
Artie's back we're back after a quick
detour in his past we it was a flashback
all the whole time we're back and son
Danny orbs on the need Jake we've been
doing the show for a we're nearing the
25th episode and unfortunately we've
kind of tapped all of our resources and
it's probably time for dirty Artie to
stop to rest this saddle to rest in
peace like so many previous Steve's
we're gonna we're gonna call it after
next episode we're gonna do one more
finale and then Jake and I decided to
put down this wonderful wonderful series
yeah it's been one of my favorite things
I've worked on at GameSpot and I'm happy
everyone has enjoyed it as much as they
have yeah
the truth is though is that it's been
super busy and we had someone else
working on us with this but he recently
left the company so it's been even more
stressful to try to get this done so we
figured it was time and when yeah when
you factor in the fact that we're maybe
not running out of ideas but we're
running out of like really good ideas
that we think could last an episode that
we think could make for a compelling
episode for sure I mean I'm surprised
we've actually gone this far it's it's
been a hell of a ride but yeah to that
point like I would hate to to force
laughter and to force you know ideas as
you kind of put it like we've we've
really tapped out yeah and on ideas for
the show but you know it's been great
you know the the I can't believe I would
never in a thousand years would have
thought that we
no way
well that really sells it that was not
expected Artie just died
we just we literally died for real
that's insane I can't believe that
happened well anyways yeah you know
everyone who stuck with the show and
wash it like you guys are awesome thank
you so much for sticking with us even
when we you know made some bizarre turns
you know it it's five minutes pace five
minutes amazing I still love it but uh
yeah that's gonna do it after next week
we're gonna do one epic finale yeah and
we saw parties for this episode too so
stick around
yeah and now it's time for show us your
RT where you submit your own
interpretations and creations of dirty
Artie and boy do we kick it off with
some good old American beans Wow I saw
it this weekend and I was cracking up
that's so good it's very good love it
cute yeah we just got this one today
very very colorful and happy and the
artist made sure to let us know that
those are in fact flies around him yep
definitely gathered that very awesome
Thank You Sara thank you
this is how 98 Nick and this one creeped
me out because the shirt and mask
combination was not good but also good
good but not good yes man that mask is
so freakin gross can he like like I
don't know it's the skin is melting off
it's so gross yeah I get right in there
yeah but it smell so bad oh thank you
love it so much
this is from rage quit and then they
have a bunch of numbers in their
username but I thank you for saying that
one in and then this one someone sent me
right before we started and I don't know
I kind of like it was from Sebastian
nice and muddy already or is that
John I can't tell looks like Artie might
be Artie but a nice and muddy nice nice
and moody to moody and muddy yeah very
moody this is like a Valentine
looks like Valentine our favorite place
our favorite town nice hatch yeah it was
from Sun of honor he sent in a lot
that's a gigantic divas a massive beaver
huge to Beaver Hollow blues nice beaver
I don't even know there were beavers in
the game yeah there's like a legendary
one too I don't know if that's it I
think it's an albino legend area beaver
but that's awesome whoa so this person
had a bunch of good ones but I picked
this one because I don't know I just
thought this one was hilarious free oh
my god it's so good I love the real
mouth oh Jesus Christ and that's all for
this week and that's it
I guess next week next episode will be
the last dirty Artie so get your already
submissions in the final episode we'll
try to do every single one that's not
true we'll try to do a lot of them we'll
try to do as many as we can thank you
guys so much again stay tuned next week
for the finale the epic conclusion
chapter 25 of dirty Artie
[Music]